-
GREAT TO SEE THIS.
MORNING LOOK FOR TO SEEING YOU
NEXT PIECE.
>> THE FORMER PRESIDENT HAS
FUMED ABOUT THE FBI SEARCH OF
MAR-A-LAGO.
FORMER FIRST PRESIDENT MELANIA
TRUMP HAS BEEN QUIET ABOUT IT.
WE'RE NOW GETTING THE FIRST
DETAILS OF HER REACTION TO THE
SEARCH.
CNN'S KEITH BENNETT JOINS --
JOINING US WITH HER NEW
REPORTING.
KATE, SHE'S ANNOYED, BUT NOT
BEFORE THE REASON HE WAS.
THINK >> LISTEN, AS DONALD
TRUMP RANTED AND RAVED AND GOES
INTO THIS VERY SPECIFIC LEGAL
BATTLE, MELANIA TRUMP, AS USUAL
AS YOU'RE SORT OF UPSET THAT
SHE WAS --
HER PRIVACY WAS INVADED.
BEING PART OF THE DONALD TRUMP
ORBIT MEANING THESE THINGS
HAPPEN.
BUT SHE WAS MORE UPSET THAT
BASICALLY PEOPLE WERE IN HER
HOME, IN HER CLOSET, SEARCHING
HER HOUSE WHERE HER SON LIVED
--
WHOM SHE IS RIGHTFULLY
PROTECTIVE OF.
BUT NOT OF SAID TO THE EXTENT
OF MAKING A STATEMENT OR COMING
TO HIS DEFENSE OR GETTING
INVOLVED IN ALL OF THIS BACK
AND FORTH WITH THE U.S.
GOVERNMENT AND THE DOJ --
THAT THE FORMER PRESIDENT IS
DOING.
SHE JUST, LIKE DON'T MESS WITH
MY STUFF.
DON'T FORM A CLOSET.
>> THEY WERE IN HER CLOSET.
THEY WENT IN HER SLEEPING
QUARTERS, WHICH ARE SEPARATE
FROM THE FORMER PRESIDENTS.
DID THEY GO THROUGH EVERYTHING?
>> IT SOUNDS LIKE THEY DID.
THE SEARCH WARRANT DID HAVE THE
RIGHT TO GO THROUGH THE ROOMS
IN A SUITE WHERE THE PRESIDENT
FREQUENT.
AS YOU JUST MENTIONED, THEY DO
HAVE SEPARATE BEDROOMS.
HER SUITE OF ROOMS DOWN THE
HALL FROM HIS.
NOT TOO FAR.
BUT THIS IS THE FIRST LADY WHO
IS NOT, YOU KNOW, HIDING A
LETTER FROM KIM JONG-UN AND HER
DRESSER DRAWER.
SHE CERTAINLY --
HIS VISIT IS SEPARATE FROM HER.
SHE NEVER LET THE TWO OVERLAP.
SHE'S VERY VOCAL ABOUT THAT.
IT'S NOT AS THOUGH HE'S, LIKE
HEY, I'M GONNA PUT THIS BOX IN
YOUR CLOSET.
THAT WAS CERTAINLY NOT THE
CASE.
AND LIKELY NEVER WILL BE FOR
MELANIA TRUMP.
>> HER BUSINESS, YOU MENTIONED,
SEPARATE FROM HIS.
SHE DOES HAVE BUSINESS.
SHE'S DOING THIS NFT THING.
>> YEAH, AND THAT'S A GREAT WAY
TO PUT.
IT THIS NFT THING.
IT'S VERY HARD TO DECIPHER.
FIRST LADY --
THERE'S NO PLAYBOOK FOR WHEN
THEY LEAVE OFFICE OF WHAT THEY
HAVE TO DO.
SOME OF THEM CHOOSE TO GO ON OR
USE THEIR INITIATIVES TO BUILD
GLOBAL PLATFORMS.
MELANIA TRUMP HAS CHOSEN TO
INVEST HER TIME INTO AN NFT
BUSINESS, WHICH IS FOR PROFIT
ON A WEBSITE CALLED USA
MEMORABILIA.
WHERE THEY SELL NFTS WHICH ARE
DIGITAL, NON-FUNGIBLE TOKEN
COLLECTIBLES LIKE 50 BUCKS.
OF MOMENTS IN THE TRUMP
PRESIDENCY.
IT'S VERY UNORTHODOX FOR FORMER
FIRST LADY TO DEVELOP A
BUSINESS THAT IS FOR PROFIT.
EXPLICITLY, AS THIS WEBSITE IS.
SHE HAS MILLIONS OF TWITTER
FOLLOWERS.
SHE DOESN'T TWEET THAT MUCH.
BUT ALMOST HALF RETWEET SINCE
FEBRUARY HAVE BEEN RETWEETS
PROMOTING THIS NFT BUSINESS AND
THE SALE OF THE SPECIFIC NFTS.
IT'S AN UNUSUAL, YOU KNOW, A
VERY STRANGE, SORT, OF PAT FOR
FORMER FIRST LADY TO NOT
CONTINUE THE GIANT GLOBAL
PLATFORM SHE HAS TO TALK ABOUT,
YOU KNOW, WHATEVER CHILDREN IN
MILAN'S INSTANCE --
BUT AGAIN, SHE SAYS --
MELANIA TRUMP HAS ALWAYS BEEN
--
FIRST LADIES ONLY GET A 20,000
PENSION A HERE WHEN THEY LEAVE
OFFICE.
AND THAT'S AFTER THE PRESIDENT
DIES.
SO IT'S NOT --